hey it's justine and today i partner
with mobilepixels to show you how you
can go from this
to this
meep gemino's this is a two screen
desktop monitor that can ultimately save
you a ton of desk space in comparison to
the traditional side-by-side monitors
these are two 24-inch 1080p 60 hertz
refresh rate displays that are stacked
on top of each other it has a sliding
mechanism that lets you adjust the
height and level of the displays it has
two usb a ports a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack two usb-c ports it has
pass-through charging two hdmi ports an
ethernet jack and a tf sd card slot it
also has a built-in 1080p webcam
speakers and touch menu buttons on the
front this will work with mac windows
linux chrome your laptop your desktop
xbox or playstation they have a few
kickstarter options so be sure to check
out the link in the description to see
if this might be for you
so this is what the display looks like
all folded up and now we're gonna raise
it up and get to work
so i have it all set up and i am so into
this layout for editing because i have
my main timeline up here i have my
browser down here which i have all of my
files now obviously these displays are
1080p and comparing them to the pro
display xdrs and the studio display is
something that you really can't compare
because it's not apples to apples those
are high-end displays and those three
displays probably cost over
what like almost 15
give or take a few so the fact that this
is a kickstarter that's happening now
they've actually already fulfilled most
of these super early bird orders so if
you guys want to check that out i'll put
a link in the description so you can see
if this is something that you're
interested in and find a kickstarter
package that is right for you so for a
lot of high-end professional editors and
photographers you are gonna need to have
a perfectly calibrated monitor but what
this is giving me is a completely new
way of working whether i'm sitting
whether i'm standing i'm able to just
adjust this i can't even tell you how
cool it is to work like this because i
love having the entire top be set up
with my timeline and my viewer and down
here i have all of my files like this is
it's game changing to be honest with you
now if i wanted to do this with my pro
display xdrs or other monitors i don't
even know how i would go about doing
that especially the ease of use of just
folding this down and having these
hinges so i've only used one cable i
have the mac studio plugged in with hdmi
into the display and it automatically
identifies that these are two displays
so you can see the different layout
right now so i'm able to arrange these
however i want so obviously the top is
on the top and you can set whichever one
you want to be your main display i also
like that this does reduce clutter
because it does have the built-in usb
dock so i have a bunch of ports that are
easily accessible i also have the sd
card slot built right into the base and
this is actually just a prototype so
this isn't the final working version
that you'll be receiving when the
kickstarter is actually send out you'll
notice that the base is a little bit
different and this is actually what it
looks like in its final form this is
pulled from their kickstarter video and
some of the photos that they've sent me
so it's been really cool getting to use
this prototype and i'm so excited to see
the final version i also have some big
plans for this display in my gaming
setup you can game on this you can
connect your xbox your playstation your
nintendo switch now since i already have
a high-end gaming monitor that i love to
use for gaming now i have my gaming
monitor which will be my kind of central
display where i play my actual games on
but i'm gonna be using this as kind of
the companion piece because i love
having extra monitors but there's never
enough space to actually put all of
these displays on on my gaming desk
because it's much much smaller but with
this i'll be able to have these two
extra displays i'll be able to put my
twitch chats and my obs stream and i'll
be able to kind of control the stream
and be able to see everything that's
going on while not taking away from my
main display that i'm gaming on now you
can actually game on this too and what
is also kind of exciting is if you don't
have a gaming monitor or you don't have
another that you use this can also be
used just like i had mentioned but
without the third monitor it's so cool
because i've never actually thought
about using displays this way and now
that i've used this i'm gonna have a
really hard time going back to having
displays that are set side by side so
i'm now in my office and i have my
stream set up all set up and this is
honestly the ideal situation having both
of these monitors connected i basically
have just added two vertical displays i
can drag and drop different windows
throughout each one so what i have
happening here is i have my main twitch
window up just to make sure everything
looks good so i can see what they see
and over here i have my obs set up so
this is where i have all my audio my
inputs the gaming coming through and
then over here i have an additional chat
window so
yeah this is actually pretty exciting
maybe this is like the piece of the
missing stream puzzle that i needed to
get me to stream
again are we back or are we back
[Music]
now a lot of times in some of my
previous videos you've seen me edit with
a vertical display which i absolutely
love doing but what's different about
this is this is not just a vertical
display this is actually two displays so
each one is acting as a separate monitor
which means you can have different
inputs in each one and the fact that i
can fold this down and change the angle
is pretty cool now i myself don't have a
standing desk yet but i do think that
this would be a really great standing
desk option because if you are standing
up you'll be able to adjust this and if
you're standing you'll have a better
kind of view of looking down at whatever
this is down here i also think this
would be great for someone who does a
lot with spreadsheets i don't do a lot
with spreadsheets but if i did hello i
am making a document i need
um
numbers
like what is the the apple excel version
again
numbers clearly i have not opened it
once look at this
i've got my
document that i'm making here
and i'm still down here
watching a youtube video this is great
this is great two two youtube channels
at the same time
so cool thank you guys so much for
watching i had so much fun getting to
check out this prototype version of the
mobile pixels geminos i'm gonna put a
link in the description where you can go
check out their kickstarter you can find
out more information about it but i feel
like i told you pretty much everything
about it already but i definitely
recommend going and watching their
kickstarter video because it was really
great with that my friends i'm gonna go
and
i don't know what i'm gonna do probably
i don't know edit some videos so see you
later bye bye
you